it was around 8:00 in the morning on
Tuesday when Belgian police shot dead a
man in Brussels suspected of killing two
Swedish football fans and injuring a
third person on Monday
night the suspect dressed in an orange
jacket opened fire then chased the fans
into a building in the city reacting to
the shooting Belgium's prime minister
said the country would not succumb to
hate last night three people left for
what was supposed to be a wonderful
sucker party two of them lost their
lives in a brutal terrorist
attack the killings took place less than
an hour before a Belgium Sweden football
match in the city's main stadium the
game was abandoned at halim for security
reasons for several hours we didn't know
what to do we stayed where we were we
feel very stressed frightened and want
to be
home Belgian prosecutors say the suspect
was a 45-year-old Tunisian National who
claimed to be a member of isil they say
he targeted swedes possibly in
retaliation for a recent string of Quran
burning incidents in Sweden the
shootings in Brussels come just days
after a man armed with a knife killed a
teacher in northern France some people
worry that Europe could be facing a new
wave of attacks this analyst says that's
unlikely but risks remain I think there
will be a heighten security for a period
because there is a risk of imported
conflict as we as we know there will be
more sance but I think also there will
be investment in
dialogue in the European Parliament a
minute silence for the victims some EU
leaders have expressed concern about
Security in Europe during the war
between Israel and Hamas Belgian
authorities say the shootings weren't
linked to the situation nevertheless
this latest attack is likely to fuel
anxiety Natasha Butler Al jazer
Brussels make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer